it's great to welcome back to the
program today Scott Adams who is the
creator of the world famous Dilbert
comic strip which I've been reading as I
mentioned last time since I was 11 years
old much to the dismay of my parents and
management gurus everywhere also author
of many books and last time you were on
Scott we sort of started with just
trying to understand your politics which
you said were to the left of Bernie but
at the same time you thought that Donald
Trump was being unfairly criticized for
some of what he had been doing is is
that still how you would generally
assess your politics yeah I mean that's
like everything it's an
oversimplification so the details matter
but in general I have a lot of
left-leaning opinions but I don't Matt
to pay for them you know I would love
universal health care for example but I
don't know how to get there
and I have very left opinions on other
topics as well okay yeah and we'll dig
in a little more to that now that 2020
is starting to take some shape in part
two of the interview but you and I sort
of reconnected on Twitter last week or
the week before over what I think is a
disagreement as to how to ascertain how
much Donald Trump's policies can be held
responsible for the instability that we
have seen in the stock market over the
last year or two so maybe we'll just go
through this in a couple parts and you
know we have plenty of time to flush it
out in the way that you want one of the
things you mentioned was that correct me
if I'm wrong you feel as though interest
rate increased decisions made by the Fed
may be more to blame or more to point to
than anything Donald Trump has done for
market instability is my understanding
fair or did I not get that right love
for the benefit of people watching this
let me give some context I have a degree
in economics good and I have an MBA an
MBA from Berkeley top Business School
just my MBA is not from Berkeley but
undergrad economics and graduate MBA so
so far we're doing okay right so if
somebody is watching us they're gonna
think you
talking ad and cartoonist why are they
even having this conversation so I want
to set that up first there so to answer
your question it the biggest impact on
the stock market is generally what the
Fed does and what interest rates are
doing the biggest impact on whether the
economy is doing well is employment if
you've got a strong employment you're
going to be ok even if those other
indicators are bouncing up and down and
especially if you have wage growth which
we have under this president
so both employment and wage growth are
good and you can almost forget about
everything else if you're trying to
figure out is the economy solid if so
the answer is yes and by the way for
context I'm not one of the people who
say that you know President Trump was a
hundred percent responsible for the
economy on the day that he took office
mm-hmm I think I think the first year of
any president you have to say it's 75
percent the last president right the the
new one is just starting to make an
impact in the first year by the second
year I think that's largely reversed or
it's getting close to reversing it's
more like it's a 75 percent Trump
economy maybe you could say I'm calling
that early maybe that's an end to the
end of the first term situation but
that's the general idea is that I I'm
not the one who says Obama gets no
credit in fact I go opposite and I would
say that in general there's no such
thing as a good president rather there
are presidents that fits specific
situations well or not and I would argue
that Obama was actually a pretty good
choice for an economy that was right on
the edge of the cliff because he was a
calm reinsuring you know a voice you
didn't think he was going to be
impulsive you thought he was gonna look
at the facts so all those things we
thought about him were probably good for
the psychology of the economy to give us
a little you know slow confidence that
built over time and I think the
President Obama's left us in good shape
at the end of his term and there was a
strong launchpad for president Trump who
I would argue through psychology as well
as policy
has taken the optimism up a level to the
point where the Fed actually had to slow
things down so when you look at the Fed
raising rates which immediately tanked
the market you have to say why did they
do that you know the the Fed only raises
rates when the economy is doing so well
there you have a risk on the upside you
have actually a risk that the economy is
too hot and that can cause problems you
know that they're you know not maybe not
as bad as a depression but they have
their own problems okay so I mean that's
a lot there so let's see if we can look
at a little bit of some of the things
there so here's why I questioned whether
you might be attributing too much to the
federal funds rate and there's a couple
data points that I would point to and
then we'll we'll see what you think
about them one is that historically
speaking the federal funds rate is still
very low it's still although higher than
it was two years ago historically it's
not at a level where which we would say
is one that would actually start slowing
the economy down in a serious way to
2.25 I mean we've had over 5% federal
funds rates even during periods of
economic expansion that would be data
point number one good can we can I just
give you a counterpoint attackers will
get lost if we go to next yeah I think
with interest rates direction is going
to be more more important to the
psychology of the market than where it
is as an absolute level because if it's
moving in a direction people say well it
could keep moving so we don't know where
this ends but the you know we want to
get ahead of it and sell our stocks in
case it keeps going so I would agree
with you that the level is still low but
that the direction is more important
than the level in least to the stock
market okay fair enough that's point one
point two would be that it's not so cut
and dry that even the direction if not
the level of increased interest rates
are actually necessarily bad for the
market in general so as one
counterexample banking stocks tend to do
better in higher interest rate
environments and in fact as interest
rates go up
would be building confidence conceivably
if you're paying attention to the
signals that banking is going to start
doing better there are other industries
where the same logic would sort of apply
so I would also question the historical
correlation between interest rates up
either in direction or in the absolute
and stock markets well but you're you're
picking the one industry banking where
they directly make more money if they
can charge higher interest rates so
there there's a you know that's a
special case let me just mention one
other just so we have just so I'm not
cherry-picking and kind of making a
special pleading if you look at real
estate in general and that that can
include many many other industries right
so large Realtors construction there's a
lot that it's under the real estate
umbrella when interest rates remain too
low this can cause too much borrowing
too much risk taking which we could
argue precipitated the housing crisis in
2008 and 2009 so I think that there's a
number of sub industries connected to
real estate which also benefit
psychologically as you mentioned and
maybe even practically from higher
interest rates I I think I would agree
with all that in the sense that the Fed
is probably doing a good job meaning
that they're they're probably quite
legitimately and based on data based on
the past etc that a little raised and
the interest rates probably makes
complete sense so I don't dispute that
fact that can be good yeah but I think
where we are disagreeing is that you're
saying that there's an obvious and
direct historical line from interest
rates up to market instability or drop
and what I'm trying to point out is that
that connection is not so clear
historically it's very clear in terms of
temporary movements of the market which
is largely what we're talking about
we're really talking about the last few
months right that that's where most of
the most of the disruption in the market
happened okay all right so so I think
the audience gets a sense of where where
we're coming from and where we disagree
let's now deal with
the tax cuts and tariffs and we can deal
with them separately or together if your
sense that one or the other or both have
precipitated any particular cohesive
sort of narrative shift in the economy
well we probably do have to talk about
them separately so on on the tax cuts
those are great for psychology great
from the perspective of business but it
does kick the can down the road in terms
of the deficit and the debt
now the thing that most non Economist's
which is you know 99.999% the world get
wrong about national debt is that unlike
personal that you don't necessarily have
to pay it back correct and that that's a
much longer conversation and more than
we can get into but the the government
could just say well we'll just pay the
interest on this as long as we want to
and if they got it down to the point
where it was no longer growing they
could just inflate it away by just
paying the interest until the amount of
the debt no longer looks big in the
future because all dollar amounts today
you know they're gonna look less
important in the future in terms of debt
so I hope that wasn't too confusing but
the the the the point is that national
debt we don't exactly know what is too
high and right now I believe as a
percentage of GDP we're getting close to
but probably not yet we may be close to
it or just crossed it the highest debt
we've ever had but we easily handled the
highest debt we've ever had in the past
I think it was after World War two and
so if we're alarmed at the level that's
probably misplaced if we're alarmed that
we don't know how to stop it from going
out forever
that's very well-placed because you know
even though national debt is different
and even though we have the big army and
you know if you have the biggest
military in the world you have options
that a homeowner getting a mortgage
didn't have so there are a lot of
variables about a national debt you know
from the fact that they can print money
they just have other options
so I'm worried that we don't have a way
to get to a lower rate of growth of debt
and nobody has the answer to that as far
as I know yeah worried that I just
looking at the level of the debt I think
is a political football that's thrown
back and forth and not the most relevant
thing what I would look to in terms of
the tax cuts is that when you look at
the story we were told about the tax
cuts they would pay for themselves and
lower lower the deficit it hasn't
happened but you and I were both saying
we actually aren't that concerned with
that so let's skip that for now but when
you look at hourly earnings unemployment
when you look at a lot of other
indicators the the curve is unchanged
from what it was carrying over in that
first year that you said was 75 percent
attributable to Barack Obama since the
tax cuts those indicators have not moved
in any way so I'm wondering where we get
the idea that if you believe that this
was a positive tax reform plan where can
we see it yeah there's a little bit of
an apples and orange comparison if
you're looking at the rate of let's say
employment improvement from Obama
through Trump so it's so your point
which i think is valid is that the the
rate was similar
so he's improved Trump is improving
employment at roughly the same way that
Obama did but here's the important
distinction yeah Obama Obama was taking
us off the bottom so the economy was at
a bottom when you're at a bottom you've
got masses of highly skilled employees
who just need an opportunity and then
they go back to work when you get toward
to full employment which is where we are
now the the economists talk about full
employment being where it where's it
three or four percent I forget but they
don't full employment in an economists
view is not zero because that would be a
problem in itself
yeah but somewhere around where we are
is pretty close to full employment when
you get there the people who are still
unemployed are unemployed for a better
reason and it's not just lack of jobs
because right now we have more jobs than
we have qualified people to take them so
I would say that Trump's ability to keep
that line still going higher
is a far far not even close level of
difficulty compared to taking things
from the bottom you know and again I
give I give Obama a full credit for
taking us from the bottom that's that's
not nothing that's a lot
let's pause our conversation there with
Scott Adams we will pick it up there and
there's plenty more to talk about on
tomorrow's program